Dr Nathan chasing horse accused of
victimizing indigenous girls and women
for two decades faced a judge earlier
today Victoria Saha was in the courtroom
she has learned a whole high-profile law
for May represented
the courtroom tents with both supporters
and alleged victims of Nathan chasing
horse present those women really
sticking together as they saw him just a
few feet away Nathan chasing horses
family and supporters made their
presence known in the courtroom for us
it was surprising to see that and they
don't necessarily represent the natives
throughout the United States or here in
Las Vegas sure if you received a copy of
the criminal complaint file against
yes
that criminal complaint found Monday's
shows chasing horses facing two counts
of sexual assault including with a minor
four counts of sex trafficking one count
of child abuse and prosecutors also say
a chasing horse had images of a minor in
a sexual portrayal on Monday we expected
to learn about bail for chasing horse
but instead who will be representing him
still needs to be sorted out
as much as possible the Los
angeles-based attorney Alexander
casarian who works for a high profile
firm garagos and garagos was there still
not his official attorney I would ask
that we put Arena over just to Wednesday
I'll be back and I should be able to
address the court at that time chasing
[__] is accused of being the leader of
a cult known as the circle and sexually
assaulting many indigenous young women
for victims seeing chasing horse in a
courtroom was a day they've been waiting
for it's a good feeling for them but at
the same time it's like reliving the the
situations they've been through and it's
unfortunate that they have to go through
that because tensions were so high court
staff tried to keep supporters and
alleged victims separate as they walked
out to avoid any confrontations Victoria
Saha 8 News Now